hey what's going on it's Bill burn it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday December 4th
2023 what's going on how are
yeah oh oh oh oh
zamic you
know Jesus Christ how many [__] times
can they play that commercial during NFL
Sunday d
so I
[__] sitting there going o zic now
you know that's got a ton of side
effects right you know it
does you know it's got a ton of that you
know a lot of people out there who
either got the jab or didn't they're
still going to take this
[__] right everything has a side effect
you know you fall in love there's a side
effect you lose your friends
um so I'm sitting there thinking like
who the [__] saying that the it's all
it's the real song is oh oh oh it's
magic when you're blowing me I don't
know I don't know how the [__] lyrics
go but whatever it's it's a romantic
song so I go to look it up because I'm
like who the [__] sold this song to this
drug company you know did they have a
bunch of hits did they only have one
there was a Scottish band named pilot
and evidently they had three hits one of
them called January and something else I
don't know what I never heard of this
[__] wait I actually got my information
in front of me this week look at me
double click you got to use the two
fingers or else you're not going to have
it all
right let's see here pilot is a Scottish
rock group formed in
Edinburg uh best known for the song
january in
O
oamic just a smile and call me
round but only January and Magic have
their own pages so I'm
imagining that those were much much
bigger uh much bigger hits whatever so
yeah they're like basically two hit
wonders they had the hit back in 1973 or
7577 around there they need some money
so Along Comes these drug pedling sons
of [__]
OIC and they go hey hey buddy buddy cuz
they're like 70 now hey over here
what aren't you the guy from Pilot and
they're like
yeah listen I got this new drug to lose
weight you know common side effects are
nausea vomiting diarrhea abdominal pain
constipation serious side effects are
pancreatis hypoglycemia gallbladder
problems allergic reaction kidney
failure changes in
Vision um other people say it could
possibly lead to thyroid cancers
pancreitis and pancreatic
cancer could we have your
song what song is it that magic
song the guys probably like oh I'm sick
of singing it yeah
okay except we're not going to go oh
it's magic we're going to go oh
zic and they're going to and he's like
what the [__] is that and then they jab
it into his neck a week later he dies of
pancreatic cancer and then they don't
have to pay him residuals that's my
conspiracy theory which I'm big on this
week I'm big on the conspiracy theories
this week because they slid in this
thing they slid it
in lubed up this bill they always have
[__] attached to a bill why can you
attach [__] to a bill I'm Just a Bill
yes I'm all oh oh oh zic like that was a
mashup for all the kids listening oh
[__] you saw what he just
did I will never understand the
fascination with mashups it's like oh my
God it's like you found two songs that
were the same tempo what is the [__]
odds of that pretty
high pretty high why why cuz white guys
hate dancing so they they try to keep it
at a certain amount of BPM so we can
just sort of walk around the [__]
dance floor and do our required one
dance at a
wedding do you have any white guys have
that contract with their wife I'm going
to dance to one song at the wedding then
I'm going back to the bar right
sweetheart all right here I go again on
the Dance
Floor walking around in a [__] Circle
till it's done
right
[Laughter]
you name one [__] thing that your
wife hates as much as you hate
dancing that you that you could possibly
get her to do in public in front of
everybody It's [__] amazing it's
amazing that they do it right so anyways
oamic I've seen that [__] commercial
like 98 [__]
times
um I want to write an answer song why
don't you have a
salad you fat
[__] there are no shortcuts there you
tubby hey there tubby tits you want to
lose a [__] you want to lose your
tits you sick of having tits you sick of
looking like a half a bull and a [__]
you look like a bull that's
transitioning to be a
[Laughter]
cow why don't you just [__] eat right
they don't want to do it they literally
this is a classic example of they
literally want to have their cake and
eat it and have abs it's not how it
works all right I got two words for you
when it comes to desserts lay
off you think that I started drinking
coffee again right I'm not I'm not I'm
just F I'm high on sobriety right now no
cigars no coffee those are my two things
and the occasional weed gummy that
occasionally gets out of control and
then I [__] you know smoke weed like
every night for like 10 days and I'm
doing what am I doing I'm not Che I'm
not Chong all right I'm Billy redface
I'm a drunk I laid off the booze don't
start another bad habit
so I don't know I don't know I got in a
good F I got in a good fight with my
wife my wife before I do that before I
before I I bring this up before I bring
this up let me let me do I got to do the
uh my tour dates for 2024 are coming out
right I love promoting right as I take a
[__] break promoting more goddamn
work that I'm GNA have to go do um all
right all my tour dates what is it here
tour date announcements for MMP all
shows pre-sale starts Tuesday December
6th with the code Burr B RR all right
and let's let's see where old Bill's
going to go h no road again chcka boom
chcka boom boom boom just can't wait to
I actually can't wait I can wait till
February I have uh the Rancho in Rancho
Mirage
California I am at the
show
agua kente Rancho
Mirage that sounds like it's going to be
a bunch of white people eating salsa all
right I got that one in February
then uh I'm just going to read where I'm
going to be you can look all of these
[__] things up okay uh Portland
Oregon Vancouver British
Columbia Salt Lake City I haven't been
there in a long time I love the Mormons
she's still a virgin she's just taking
it in the ass Gary Indiana in March oh
why you going to Indianapolis bill on
March 9th cuz I got a show at the
gamebridge field
house um Detroit Michigan at the Little
Caesars
arena St Louis Missouri oh these are all
fun Blue Collar [__] baseball
football [__] town basketball towns
St Louis
Missouri um Phoenix
Arizona Columbus Ohio this is in May
Nashville Tennessee Winston Salem North
Carolina getting down there the Tobacco
Road uh Denver San Jose winning
Peg London Ontario and then I have a a
uh I have I can sort of tease this I'm
going to a different continent I'm going
to a
continent that I've never been to before
that's also coming up next year oh it's
going to be
fun trying to line it up with the Moto
GP race giving you some hints here
giving you some hints so anyway I had a
great little [__] battle with my wife
right I'm sitting there about ready to
go out to dinner friend of ours it was
her birthday right and I'm laying there
and I'm watching uh I'd watched
Alabama roll tide roll over them [__]
rescue dogs of Georgia the Georgia
Bulldogs I was rooting for Georgia you
know because I'm just not I mean I love
I've always loved Alabama and I've
always you know got to respect Nick sa I
loved Alabama back when they had Bear
Bryant but like I didn't watch college
football for a long time so when I came
back just to give you the backstory just
in case you're new to the podcast I
wasn't going to just bandwagon and jump
on the Juggernaut that is Alabama
football but I have respected them so
um you know I thought when they uh when
they had that exchanged in the fourth
quarter and they fumbled the ball and Al
Georgia did and Alabama recovered it I
literally sent to all my buddies on the
football text uh that Robert Shaw and
Jaws when he goes farewell and too my
little Spanish lady farewell Ado oh
ladies of Spain whatever that whole
thing I was just just like that's it
they get a punch it in here for a
touchdown this game's over unbeknown to
me they only got a field goal and they
kind of went back and forth you guys saw
the game so they won
it I mean unbeliev I'm telling you
there's an Unwritten rule Alabama can
only have one loss and they have to be
in the playoffs playoffs and then
Washington beats Oregon and all of a
sudden you start hearing Ohio State's
name being brought up and I'm just say
you got to be [__] kidding me these
[__]
guys they get in even when they don't
get in every [__] year and I started
thinking the conspiracy is if Michigan
and Ohio State ever met each other in
the playoffs playoffs for the
championship that would be the highest
rated I would think right that would be
like I don't know Alabama and Auburn or
uh
USC
um so I'm watching the Michigan Iowa
game which once again the under came in
got to give a shout out to my my my
buddy in high school keeps telling me
the Iowa under the Iowa under the Iowa
under this year and and and ever since
he told me that it was 272 the Iowa
under came in it was 252 the lowest
under over under college football
history final score 13- 10 23 points
you're a winner I guess with the uh the
Michigan game I remember they they were
up 10 to nothing at the half and they're
going well does this affect Michigan's
rating it's like Iowa has an incredible
defense and they're offense stakks if
you're up 10 to nothing on them it's
like you're up like you know 21 nothing
it's like three godamn scores there so
Bill are you going to get to the part
where you had the fight yes I
am yes I am so I
um I ended up
uh I don't know they went to some side
some sideline reporter this lady who
does a wonderful job or whatever I got
to say this because so she's sitting
there going like and Jim Harbaugh was
say at the half you know I asked him
about this player on Iowa and you know
uh you know he said he didn't hit me he
still didn't have an answer for it and I
yelled to the TV I'm like well he's not
going to [__] tell you sweetheart why
would he say on TV what he's going to
[__] do and then I just was like I
just don't [__] get this is like
football this was a way to get away from
women and now they they're all over the
place like like they [__] you know
you just can't get away from them and I
saw a C I'm like why why can't they just
[__] why don't they do the WNBA and
women sports and just have all the guys
do guy Sports we'll watch our [__] you
watch your [__] we'll be away from each
other absence makes the hardc fer and
she's like do you know how ignorant you
found right now and da D starts reading
me the right X so you know me you know
me I'm like a [__] Ginger Wolverine I
[__] I just dig in and I go even
harder I basically started making the
points I made in my [__]
bit going like why like whatever the
thing I did on Red Rocks whatever long
story short how the fight ended I just
looked at her and I go do you realize
how far feminism has come that I
literally have to sit here and act like
I'm excited that there's a woman on the
sidelines at an NFL football
game I have to pretend that I'm happy
about that I'm not like overly upset
about it but like she goes why don't you
like him there I go because the coach
has to change his [__] demer cuz he's
talking to a
lady you know I like when Parcels when a
guy would ask a dumb question he go what
what did you say you stupid [__] I'll
rip your dick off and feed it to your
mother right next question whatever he
used to say you can't do that with a
woman you go oh it's a woman I think
it's a dumb question but if I tell her
that she said a d something stupid I'm
going to be considered
misogynistic there's got to be a place
where can you
go you know
do we infiltrate your brunch I don't
know it was just it was a stupid [__]
argument right so
then so then it's just just like you
know we're experienced we're an
experienced couple at this point so
she's just go are we really going to do
this before we go out and bring this
energy to dinner and you know in my head
I said no but I didn't say anything to
her so then she starts going
like you know like when when they're
over it and you're not quite over it and
then they just start to have like a
[__] like small talk
conversation trying to like bring it
around
like you want to do maybe some Christmas
shopping for
the with the kids for the kids tomorrow
and I'm just like yeah all right
cool asked me a couple more set
questions I'm just like yeah all right
cool but I'm not looking at her she's
like are you like still mad at me and
it's like well I'm not happy I'm like no
I'm over it she goes well you're not
looking at me when you're talking to me
so I just [__] look at her and stare
at her you know what I mean it's just
like how much of the why don't you just
get some batteries and put them in my
back and just [__] remote control
me I don't know it was just one of those
things where you
know it was stupid I shouldn't have said
it I [__] said
it I I meant it in the moment but
afterwards I don't give a [__] that
they're on the sideline I don't give a
[__] you know I don't this is what I
really think I don't think anybody
should be on the sideline I don't like
when the [__] the guys run into the I
like the mystery of
it I don't want you the guy's like
running half off the field and then he
has to [__] talk to
you like this whole weird thing you know
I was watching a little bit of that Duke
Georgia Tech basketball game and they
got this camera angle where you're just
hovering over the [__] game I'm like
what am I doing right
now am I losing oxygen to my brain am I
fantasizing that this is happening right
now I feel like I'm I'm it's like I'm
riding in a
drone um oh Billy Oldman is coming out
in
force so I mentioned earlier that uh The
Conspiracy Theory I'm trying to stay
away from it because last night I went
to dinner and there was a couple people
like talking
conspiracy you know saying like sunblock
is actually all [__] uh the sun
doesn't cause cancer what causes cancer
is what you eat and act skin cancer what
actually causes cancer is putting that
[__] on your skin I'm like guys you know
I'm I'm trying to [__] you
know trying to have an appetizer here
all
right of all the conspiracies you could
bring up are you really going to talk to
a ginger about sunblock and say that
it's going to give him cancer I don't
[__] need that so
um and of course I'm taking it all in
going yeah this is [__] this I bet
this is true right so
um I wake up this morning and I end up
seeing something online where it says
all cars in
2026 are going to be required to have a
kill switch that the cops and the
government can basically shut off your
[__]
car and of course then then this is the
thing they attach it to a bill which is
about something
else probably should kids have healthy
drinking water you know why yes they
should all in favor yes and then
attached to it is this this another
level of [__] control they're saying
that it's for drunk
drivers and it's like all right well
what do you have to do take a
breathalyzer to get into your [__]
car I mean I wouldn't mind that I don't
give a [__] about
that you know but a kill switch so you
can't like leave or
Escape so then all of a sudden it
becomes this thing where if all of a
sudden if they want to like make sure
nobody goes anywhere
they can shut off everybody's car in
like 10 years once 90% of people are
driving like a car that's by
2036 so here's how you beat that
everybody cuz what we're going to do
right now is we're all going to like
everybody on the right's going to be
thank you Joe Biden for the kill switch
thing like he came up with this like Joe
Biden comes up with anything he's lost
his [__] mind he should be in a home
right they're going to blame blue ties
and red ties if if if Trump had won the
election this [__] would still be
happening because the president doesn't
run anything I've been telling you this
forever the president is basically when
you have a delayed flight at the airport
you know that person behind the counter
that you yell at you know and you say
I'm never flying your airline again like
it's their Airline it's not their
Airline whoever owns the airline you're
never going to meet them you're never
going to know their [__] name they
don't even fly the airline they fly
private that's what the president is so
this is easily defeated if people would
do
it all right all you do is everybody
just starts walking to
work you just start walking everywhere
and everybody just uses less gas okay
and the oil companies other than the
banks is probably the biggest dick that
the [__] politicians have to
suck you know other than the
banks so if all of a sudden they're not
getting them
money and they can't buy their
Yachts you know the the [__] guys at
that level that are that are competing
with like the Amazon
guy like why is this nerd with his
package company living across the street
from
me I'm an oil
Baron I'm an oil Baron I should have a
bigger house than this [__] they
probably get involved in petty [__] like
that you know they sit at night and
they're upset because on one side of
them is the guy from Amazon and on the
other side is the guy who created
[__] two guys a girl in a pizza place
and they're sitting there're like hey
just like these people are beneath me
you [__] you're a glorified UPS guy
and and and you made a [__] sitcom
and you're next to
me my company starts
Wars I need a bigger [__] house right
so here's the deal if everybody just
starts [__] walking nobody's going to
do this right cuz that'll be too hard I
live too far away you can ride a bicycle
buy one of those little [__] electric
bikes right and then if we all go to
work if we all walk to
work guess what you won't need anymore
oh oh oh oh
zamic you
know we're riding to work this is what
what we should all do over the next what
do we got we got two years to get ready
for the kill switch everybody goes out
and buys a
bicycle all right and you get extra
points if you buy the three- wheeled one
so you got a big Basket in the back for
your fat neighbor and you can [__]
you know get him down the hill or
whatever on the level
ground help the guy you let I don't know
I was going to say let fat people dry to
work I have no
idea
um anyway there is ways around we could
we could defeat all of these things
things if they hadn't divided us with
politics race
sexuality nationalism and all of that
it's [__] it's one of the most
brilliant things it's just [__]
brilliant evil so now they're going to
be able to shut your [__] car
off um but here's the thing they ain't
going to get me because when I buy a car
I fall in love with it and I drive it
into the
ground that's it so I'm just going to
keep my car and then at some point
you
know will you be required oh dude that's
a [__] movie right there a movie
right there 20 years from
now it's up to
[__] it's up to old people and broke
ass people that are driving at least
20-year-old cars that don't have kill
switch kill switches to rise up against
an oppressive New World
Order and they end up defeating it
driving like 2019 [__] uh Challengers
and [__] I don't know whatever what I
don't even know what the cars names are
anymore they all look like [__] ovals
to me with wheels on them I did go out
and get the Christmas trees today oh
Christmas tree oh Christmas
tree I took some OIC my stomach hurts I
bought the tree
and I feel like a jerk anyway uh yeah
this the first year I didn't I didn't
take the F100 I had the F250 with the
fullsize [__] bed unlike all you
other [__] with your glorified station
wagons that you're calling a truck with
your four-door [__] trucks with that
little hot tub [__] bed you got back
there you don't have a truck if your
Christmas tree is is hanging off the
back like [__] Ace Ventura sticking
his head out the window that's not a
truck if you can't stick a [__] 8ot
goddamn Christmas tree in the back so I
had that one in the back and uh then I
always get my uh my daughter one my son
isn't old enough for one I think by next
year I'll have to get him one too so I
put it in her room
and you know I bring the tree stands
back right they hook it up everybody's
cool I [__] tip everybody cuz I'm a
big shot and I'm driving down the street
and the love L Nia love of my life right
my best friend who I [__] argue with
about [__] chicks on the sideline
which is so stupid I [__] she texts
me this is the best part about being
married man woman they whatever is when
the person you [__]
married you know goes make sure you blah
blah blah blah blah and you already did
it she sent me a text message she goes
make sure you get our daughter a
Christmas tree don't
forget and the next light I turned
around and I took a picture of both
trees in the bed of my truck and I sent
the photo to her and then I wrote don't
ever insult me with a question like that
[Laughter]
again [__] think I'm going to forget
to get her the tree I'm not going to lie
to you I forgot for half a second but I
remembered up with the register I'm like
oh wait I got to get her one um but I
was also in my I don't want to upset
anybody because the parking lot was full
all right and I had my big
rig you know what you know what my truck
has had in the in the bed let me see
here it's had two Christmas trees this
is how much my truck is like when I if I
ever go to sell this like how much money
it's going to be worth cuz it doesn't
have a kill switch it's going to be a
whole section of meum auctions coming up
next we got some no kill switch [__]
power coming up we got a two 2,000
[__] 23 F250 you're going to be able
to like [__] bid on those things
probably in the
future um any I don't know what the [__]
I'm talking about here uh I just
realized I'm got a bunch of cards out
here I'm writing another script and you
know this this is the experience after
you've written one movie you know what I
did when I had these things all laid
out I I numbered all of
them so that way inevitably when they
get get pushed around or something like
that over the course of the months I can
just put them right back together
see what your dealing with here people
is the thinking man
um
so anyway I got most of my Christmas
shopping done um I got two things lined
up to get my wife I'm going to get it
one more thing all right she's getting
the old threepiece here and then what do
you do you always got to get him some
stupid [__] I don't know extra [__]
just so they have something else to open
and uh this year I asked for I want to I
want to take a barista
class um and then I also want to take
one of those [__] Drive-In classes
where they teach you how to drive a car
around the track using the throttle
rather than turning the steering wheel
the whole way like I was telling you
guys uh on the last
podcast I'm going do like the
experiences um and I'm going to start
start giving away [__] in my office I
got all kinds of books and stuff like
that whatever you want if you're into
them I'll sign them if that's what you
want to do I won't sign them I just
don't want to throw them out and have
them in the [__] ocean you know
although they are trees they will
biodegrade I'm basically going to keep
like my high school
yearbooks and
uh what else is a couple here that I'm
going to
keep aren't
there nothing that I'm looking
at Bill Walsh find The Winning Edge I
got to keep that right um
anyway plowing ahead here you guys watch
the Pats [__]
charges I had that game on Jesus
Christ both of those teams man this guy
in the booth said it he goes these teams
just cannot move the ball down the
field defenses are looking Unstoppable
today um in the Chargers wow what a
cuple what a couple of setback years for
those two teams huh so this week I
picked the
Lions these games haven't happen yet the
Lions happened I had the Lions I got the
Eagles plus three I think I took the
Packers I can't
remember and then I got the Rams minus
three and a half I hate the fucking0
five I hate the fucking0 five and I
stayed away from the
Texans and they ended up I think they
covered I think they beat the Broncos
who knows
who knows um anyway all right let's do
the uh let's do the reads here walking
all around my frakin officegarage here
oh by the way Dean Del Ray sent me this
[__]
thing I gotta I gotta show you this he
sent me this all-star
band with Dave
[Music]
Gro um it's just a half hour the most
epic [__] music I think I I now that
I brought it up let me let me just look
so I can find the thing here I just do
that instead of being like what [__]
cuz then I'll forget and then I'll get
all these emails going like Bill what
the [__] you brought the [__] up and
then you didn't say anything here's
something and this is great if you want
to do a half hour on the
elliptical uh it says Dave Gro play
Warren Hayes presents the benefit
concert volume 20 vinyl volume or
something just whatever just Dave Gro
Warren Hayes presents it's just some of
the most
[__] some of the most epic [__] I
don't know the whole vibe of it and just
everybody could play it's Chris Cheney
on Bas and then I think it was the that
that extra guitar player that they
brought out I want to say it was him on
the uh Them Crooked vultures tour which
I I was there I saw it I I was at the
will turn I saw that uh speaking of that
I'm going to go to the Queens of the
Stone Age concert I'm excited about that
but I I have reads I have to do here oh
Billy
reads oh oh oh [__] AIC stop singing
that song I can't get it out of my head
where is where are my [__] where's my
emails where are my emails yes I still
have a mouse yes I still have a desktop
computer yes I'm [__] old
all right yeah well you say what you
want [__] they ain't got no
[__] switch on my car that's what
they're going to call it and if you
remove it you know it's going to be a
[__]
felony I'll tell you what's funny is
these
[__] these [__] hackers they're
going to figure out a way to just push
that thing just to [__] with people as
you're going down in the goddamn left
lane like how much more [__] control
do they have to have over us I just I
don't understand it it's like you got to
us we're going to have a kill switch on
the car we're going to microchip all of
them you know what this is for it's for
when they come up with the robots to
replace us and when we try to Rebel
we're not going to be able to go
anywhere we're not going to be able to
drive anywhere they're going to know
exactly where the [__] we are and then
your [__]
twin your AI Twin's going to come in and
[__] just choke you out so there's no
bodily fluids no you might [__] your
pants when does but there's no [__]
there's no mess and then they just like
you won't even know it like your
neighbors all got killed and were
replaced by were killed by their AI
[__] Replacements they're all going
to be [__] gone and you're going to
be coming across the street talking
about him talking to him you're not even
going to notice it until you offer him a
coffee and he says he doesn't want one
and it's that's that's weird Frank loves
coffee he can't drink it then you go to
the house he can't drink it well that
doesn't mean anything yes it does he
loves [__]
coffee you know and then what if he what
if Frank just decide to lay off coffee
for 10 days like I just did and then you
go
out and you go to blow his robot head
off and your and all of a sudden brains
come out you're like oh
[__] you know and you jump in your car
you drive halfway down your driveway and
they flick the kill switch with the
flick of the
switch that's that's what they should
have done in the Senate they should have
played ACDC flick of the switch and then
they could have sold it then we all
would have been cool with it all right
look who it is everybody it's old
zip
C host ad lib talk about some of your
favorite holiday movies um favorite
holiday movies Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that has a Christmas scene is
it doesn't it no I don't know I just
think a guy hammered in his pool
drinking [__] margarit is out of a
picture to me that's It's a Wonderful
Life um I'll tell you one that I saw the
other
day the one that I saw the I saw a
little bit of it I don't know what the
name of it
is um it's got the guy in it from the
movie who's married to that
chick oh my God how long have I been
[__] I got to stop poking the cell
phone up to my head I can't remember
anybody's name what what [__] holiday
movies do I like
all right I like all those clamation
ones Santa Claus is coming to
town oh I like
elf um Die
Hard that's a good one anyway to make
these holiday classic it takes a team of
talented people from actors to editors
to props people the sound crew and more
and when it comes to building such a
team whether it's for the entertainment
industry or a wide range of other
Industries you need to hire the right
people the best way to do that well you
know what it is everybody you know what
it
is you do know what it is it's all
[Music]
zip and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com bur how does
zip help you round up the brightest team
well they have powerful matching
technology and with the way corporations
are sharing information you know they
already got your retin in your
fingerprints uh zi procurer uses this to
find Qualified people for a wide range
of roles invite to apply see a top
candidate you're really interested in no
problem zi recruiter makes it easy to
send them a personal invite hey big boy
huh you want to look at spreadsheets to
encourage them to apply attention
grabbing labels
zip offers labels for your job post that
for your job post that speak to
flexibility like remote training
provided and more so you get the
applicants you want you know why they
want you to work from home right you
know why don't you that's so when your
AI replacement comes they can kill you
in the house it's not at work and and
their hands are clean I'm tying it all
together man uh make your hiring a
little merrier with
zip that's my favorite one the heavy
metal devil Read um it starts going
forward with zip and then we rewind it
four to five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day uh just go to this
exclusive web address right now to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
bur again that's ziprecruiter.com bur
spellout bur buur R zip
recruiter the smartest way to
hire just you know that's like [__]
what's her name what's her name there
Mary L Retton the way I stick that
Landing policy
genius um policy genius did you ever you
ever hear that Bruce Jenner the reason
why he became Caitlyn was because he was
jealous of Mary
letton just how good she looked in that
American flag bathing suit that she was
wearing but for some reason was doing
gymnastics and was not swimming I'm just
going straight conspiracy theory I'm
just going to see how many of these will
stick just write these on Reddit see if
anybody will do it all right policy
genius the holidays not only allow us to
spend time with the family but are a
reminder of how important our
responsibility is to protect them that
includes planning to secure their
Futures life insurance is an easy way to
give your family peace of mind you know
in the future they're actually going to
have a a kill switch on you as a
[Laughter]
person and when you don't do what they
want they just shut off your life switch
it becomes the kill switch and that's
why you need life insurance from policy
genius uh if something were to happen to
you your family can cover expenses while
getting back on their feet luckily po
policy genius helps you compare your
options from top companies and their
team of license experts are on hand to
help talk you through it oh luckily they
help you compare options from top
companies and their team of license
experts are on hand to talk you through
it even if you you already have a life
insurance policy through work it may not
offer protection your family of course
it doesn't your family needs and it may
not follow you if you leave your job
unless you're a
CEO you get the golden parachute uh with
policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just
$292 per year for $1 million of coverage
some options offer same day uh approval
and avoid unnecessary medical exam exams
policy genius knows how valuable your
time is the technology is easy uh makes
it easy to compare life insurance quote
from America's Top insurers in just a
few clicks to find your lowest price
policy genius has license Awards W
winning agents who can help you find the
best fit for your needs your family
deserves peace of mind a life insurance
policy through policy gen can give it to
them head to policygenius.com click the
link in the description to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you could save that's policy genius.com
here's a question I would ask Dave
Groll like how do you like play guitar
in a band for a whole damn tour right do
all these world tours and all that and
you can still play drums that good like
I wonder how long it takes them to get
like back up to speed this is total nerd
drum
talk like that he just he comes back
it's like he never stopped
playing you know I don't know you know
what it is I I just know what it's like
when I don't play drums for a
[Laughter]
while for some reason I would think that
he would have the same problem yeah bill
yeah I would say you're on the same
level as Dave croll you [__] Guitar
Center [__] dad you I'm an idiot
anyway um you got to check that out
though I'm telling you his his playing
in that everybody's playing the Dynamics
the
vibe um I got to find out more about
that concert where it
was why I missed it and all of that I've
only seen Dave Gro play drums live I've
seen the Foo Fighters a bunch of times
but I've only seen him play drums live
once
and that was when I saw that um Them
Crooked
vultures uh
concert I blew it so many times I should
have seen him in Nirvana I should have
seen him when he did that tour with
Queens of the Stone
Age oh the amount of shows the amount of
shows that I've missed um anyway but
that's what not what life is about you
don't think about the shows you missed
everybody you think about the shows you
went to you know
like when I saw Fleetwood Mack when
Lindsay Buckingham had already left I
think that that was a good one
um Peter Green was gone lindsy
Buckingham came back and I just I don't
know I don't know what version of that
one that I saw was that was like the
uh you know when they have a strike
season and they have like scabs they had
like two scabs in the band and then the
rest were sort of 70s error to original
members anyway why don't I shut the [__]
up and
read read some of the uh ain't putting a
goddamn kill switch on my [__]
truck do you know what I do love about
Gearheads is they'll figure out a way
around it you know and what I actually
respect about hackers is they'll figure
out a way around it too
um that's what I you know remember why
we used to always steal cable you get
one of those little black boxes there's
got to be a way you know they'll make it
a
felony well so what I'm self-employed
what I can't I can't vote anymore it
doesn't [__] matter anyways I voted
for Bernie Sanders these last two
[__] elections and you made it
impossible you just like no [__] you
Hillary Clinton [__] you Joe
Biden [__] [__] um anyway saying
hello hey Billy Beluga tits come on man
dude you guys are going to be impressed
with me in 2024 you're going to think
it's AI bill I am uh I am doing really
well oh Billy no bread Billy no sugar
Billy no desserts Billy no
fun laying off the
coffee laying off the cigars look at all
the [__] energy I have I mean it's
safe to say I've been a I've been a loud
[__] idiot through this whole podcast
um say hello okay saying hello Billy
Beluga tits uh longtime f/p podcast
listeners I've seen you a ton over the
years thank you thank you for coming out
but my favorite show was one year when
you performed in a white suit at the
Orpheum in in La for New Year's Eve oh
yeah I remember that you know what was
happening simultaneously was mle crew
was having their farewell show at the
Staple
Center remember that they signed that
contract we will not come back and tour
ever again if we do we will Su ourselves
and they're and they're back I'm glad
they're back um at okay [__]
hilarious show my wife and I had a great
time old dads was great man we enjoyed
it especially myself as a new dad 32
years old with the four
four-month-old that's not old I mean
maybe it's old for your first one in a
military town or something that's not
old you're you're you're good um I saw
you at the LA Auto Show with who I
thought was Dean Del re yes you did I
wanted to stop by and say what's up and
also tell Dean he has a sick singing
voice yes he does I saw you guys jamming
out in an Instagram video a while back
and I started following Dean since
then all right this is just all
complimentary so far it's almost like I
wrote it and you're also one of the most
underrated 55y old [__] bald Ginger
dad drummers out there no he didn't
write that uh anyway for the question
are you fine with fans coming up to you
and saying hello the way I read the
situation in the moment it didn't seem
like the time or the place might be
different if I ran into you at the store
or after a show although I did run into
you at The Comedy Store once and you
were less than pleased but probably was
due to how I
approached yeah that's probably what
happened cuz I don't I usually don't it
usually doesn't bug
me um when I'm at a show um anyway hope
you enjoyed the LA Auto Show although it
was a bit of a bust this year with so
many Brands not there isn't that the
truth thanks and go [__] yourself um I I
don't know I don't I don't mind I don't
mind if people come up and say hello to
me as long as they're not
uh you know weirdos you know if I'm out
with my kids and everything like that I
mean that is not my favorite thing but I
also understand that like I've brought
this on myself by being in this business
so this is what I if you're cool I'm
cool if you're [__] weird I'm going
to get weirded out cuz I don't know what
you're going to do so uh you know and
then there is the outside thing you know
I am a human being if I'm not in a good
mood if I'm in a rush if I had a bad set
like I won't be as cordial but the thing
you guys have in your favor I have a
crushing need to be
[Music]
liked so there's a few times I said no
not now and then I'll walk by ah wait a
minute wait a minute I just I can't I
can't do it so um yeah but I mean it's a
great problem to have you know because
I've lived the other thing being in this
business nobody knows who I am and get
doesn't give a [__] so I mean if that's
the price I have to pay that is all
right so there you go but if I'm with my
kids I would appreciate it if I could
just have the dad time um but other than
that I I don't mind I usually just start
breaking balls when somebody comes up to
me if they seem cool like I said if you
come up and you seem weird I I get I get
[__] you know I get all es skar like
what is this what is this person going
to do all right
converted my
husband oh
Jesus hi Bill long time I like how open
ended converted what to listen to my
podcast converted him to my
comedy brought him into some religious
cult converted my husband uh hi Bill
longtime podcast listener and a huge
fan unfortunately I'm no longer allowed
to listen to you on loudspeaker because
my husb husband is and I quote tired of
this old man just yapping and
complaining about absolutely
nothing it has to be unhealthy for him
and
you I mean I can't argue any of that
your husband sounds like a [__] smart
guy so now whenever I listen to to your
podcast on my earbuds I feel like a
fatty sneaking a Big Mac is this
cheating on my husband no he he can't
tell you what you can and can't listen
to um
no longer allowed Jesus
Christ I
mean you know I'm not trying to cause a
fight but you know you can it's a
podcast I'll just I just won't listen to
it when you're around you know anyway
anyway she says I forced him to come to
your show with me in Syracuse to confer
convert him to the dark side he did feel
out of place in the sea of carheart hats
and flannel
shirts despite him looking just as pale
as everyone else in the end he loved
your show and laughed out loud a couple
of times ah look at that fast forward a
couple weeks later he was the one who
pointed out that old dads is on Netflix
and we should watch it together he's a
old he's a he's a billy old director fan
now look at that during the Thanksgiving
break we also watched Leo together with
my in-laws and my three-year-old
daughter we loved it such a great movie
for Aged 3 to 73 congratulations on
everything so far I can't wait to watch
your special when it's on Netflix loving
this bill old dad eror sincerely a
Singaporean fan in New York
um well that's great I'm I'm psych that
you converted him but he also wasn't
wrong I felt like I was in a bit of a
funk for the last couple of months
because I was just really overworked and
I was I was smoking cigars every day and
[__] drinking cof I was in survival
mode when I was out on the road and I
wasn't paying attention to [__] I had
nothing to really talk about so I
probably was just going on bitching
about [__] nothing as opposed to this
week when I I feel like I'm bitching
about something you
know entric what I can't remember the
name of it oh oh
oh what the [__] entric it's not entric
I can't
remember oh I was singing it early oh
good it's out of my [__]
head Oh Billy no short term memory here
I talked about kill switches I talked
some conspiracy
theory and I talked and I talked all
return return to reading hey Billy
Bookworm you've been bitching a lot
about how you fell out of the habit of
reading and I think a lot of people
sympathize it's too easy to get quick
doses of stimulation with our phones oh
by the way you know I got a message from
my phone said my my cell phone usage my
daily usage was down by 30 something per
and said I only looked at my phone for 6
hours and something I was like
what there's no way I'm staring at my
phone for 6 hours and I think well I
play games on it I go to the gym there's
like listening to music
count six [__]
hours you know what happens is I watch
TV and when I'm watching TV I watch a
lot of old shows and I just start going
who's that actor are they still alive
what did they end up doing and I start
looking them up on my I'm doing research
on the show that I'm now not watching
it's really bad all right so this person
says my hot take is that all
shorts all
shorts s h o r TS forms of media like
Instagram reels Tik Tok YouTube shorts
Etc should be banned entirely they are a
poison and it breaks my heart to see
corporations feeding kids this addictive
content before they have the wherewithal
to even recognize what addiction is
kids I mean I felt for it too I now you
know what my new philosophy with my
phone is me being on my phone in front
of my kids is I might as well be smoking
in front of them it's just a bad thing
to show them it's showing them that you
know sometimes my my daughter will be
like Dad Dad and I I'll be like what you
know cuz
I'm watching somebody [__] killing It
on drums or something like that and like
I get like upset for half a second that
she's that my daughter's talking to me
then I go oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I got
to put this thing down um so anyway I I
agree with you on the bright side a
group of 40 States is
suing mea meta for knowingly making
dopamine manipulating features and
fueling the youth Mental Health
crisis we are experiencing or fueling
the youth Mental Health crisis we are
experiencing so hopefully something
comes from that here is the link if
you're interested an NPR article I love
that 40 States got together in sue a
corporation
do you know I went into uh what the [__]
Nordstroms I go into Nordstroms I go
into the [__] toy section you know
pajamas for kids and everything and then
they had like this little like artsy
thing that looked like kids made and
there was a few spaces open I was like
oh is this something for kids to do I
can't remember if I told you guys I
[__] it was right near the register
and then I I look where I think there's
a sign way in the corner and I think
it's explaining the the little Art
Exhibit thing that they had and I look
at it and it says warning something
about like there's Mercury in our
glasses that could cause cancer and blah
blah blah blah buy them at your own
[__] risk and I'm thinking like well
why don't you sell different glass
frames you're not talking about drinking
glasses like what are you talking about
here and why does that little sign make
you
exempt
um I'm telling you people we we we
really got to stop this concern
conservative liberal horeshit and we
need to all get on the same page which
will never [__] happen but it would
be ni if if you're intelligent if you
look at it things if you look at things
rationally if people are calling you a
Centrist that's all good things all
right that means you look at [__]
rationally because sometimes you need to
look at it conservatively sometimes you
need to [__] let it run a little bit
you
know sometimes you need to hack a kill
switch on your 2026 Camry um if you want
to if you want to if you want help
[__] went Porky Pig there if you want
help maintaining your habit of reading
maybe you can Leverage The listeners to
keep you on track why not a start a
billy book club BBC for short you can
read along with listeners and it would
give you something else to talk about on
your podcast that's actually a [__]
great idea if it gets popular you could
start awarding your favorites a stamp of
approval like Oprah I never thought
Oprah read those books she was too busy
like ruling the entertainment industry
how does she have time to read a 400
page book every week except instead of a
fat o it's a pair of old freck freckled
Ginger balls I love every aspect of this
idea a fun book to hear you talk about
that's been brought up on the podcast
before is Catch 22 it's a very fun it's
a very funny satire punctuated by
incredibly moving insight into the
depravity and futility of War it also
has cars planes and hores so you should
have the ability to keep up just fine
the offer the off offer the author
Joseph I just said offer and I thought
this guy's last name was Hitler the
author Joseph heler has an incredible
comedic mind that I think you would
appreciate just make sure you buy a
version with chronological references as
the order of events in the book is
difficult to keep straight thanks for
all the laughs loved old dad and go [__]
yourself well that's a good idea I'm
currently uh reading Reggie
Watts's the brilliant Reggie Watts's
autobiography you know I got the kids I
don't have time to I I read like a
chapter a night like I'm not going to be
somebody who's going to be like burning
through books like I read that book on a
flight from here to [__]
Missouri like how did you do that was it
a joke book these [__] people that
can just burn through it like that's I'm
not I'm not built that way all right you
might be built that way that is not how
I am built
um anyway well just like that look at
that we did a we did a goddamn hour and
I you know what I'm going to say this is
one of my better podcasts in recent
memory because I'm [__] clear
clear-minded here um so today is my 10th
day this is what I used to do I used to
go 10 day a 10day [__]
cleanse of none of this [__] and um
I think I might start doing that with
like social
media you know I'll just make some
videos or whatever whatever the [__] I
need to
make you know give them to the great
Andrew themess have him post them or I
could just post them that doesn't mean
I'm on it right I'm not looking at it
look at this I'm already [__]
cheating I could just have one drink
right I could do a lineup blow
um anyway
uh I kind of like this man I I I like
the uh I I I don't miss coffee but for
some reason I I feel compelled that I
need to go back to it because I have
nothing else to do whatever that
means
so I don't think that's a good reason to
go back I'm definitely going to go back
I mean I got to I mean what I'm not
going to drink C I'm never going to
[__] drink bourbon
again the Sweet Taste of [__]
bourbon the sweet sounds of a senseless
argument
afterwards
um no I had my fun with booze I I have
no problem not drinking booze and I got
to be honest with you when I go out
every once in a while I I get one of
those uh alcohol-free beers and they
just have hop it's hops flavored hop
flavored [__] uh soda water and
they're they're good they used to be
terrible I don't know maybe I just
haven't had beer in so long although
last night oh my God at this
dinner there was this Irish guy there
and he was talking
about how he went to an Irish Pub out
here in LA and that they didn't pour His
Guinness right they didn't have the
glass at a 45 degree angle had it
straight up and down you saw all the
bubbles and he just said you're going to
have to repour that and you know he was
an Irish guy so he had the accent and I
was talking to him about it
and oh my
God out of all the booze that I miss on
a [__] cold day day a pint of [__]
Guinness you know something if I ever go
off the
wagon I I would be in
Ireland and it would be a
Guinness oh God when imagine if it was
[__] rainy
out you
know oh just [__] sitting there with
some old guy cracked up face and [__]
up
teeth in the middle of nowhere out in
the
countryside not saying a [__] word to
each
other just [__] drinking oh my God I
got to shut up or I'm going to go off
the [__] rails right now um I I used
to I used to love that bodington I used
to love it in the can with that little
[__] marble rolling around whatever
the [__] that thing
was um black and
tan that was the [__]
I remember one oh [__] my mouth is
watering right now I remember one time
be funny imagine I just kept going and
like this podcast became like an hour
and 40 minutes long and like the last 40
minutes of it was me walking down to a
liquor store and you hearing it opening
opening up and then I just went off the
rails and totally ruined my [__]
career but like you would just have you
you would have it documented like when
it happened you would have the audio you
know and none of you guys would give a
[__] you just animate the whole thing
and have a great time and turn it into
memes right which would be perfect
right anyway I was in antor
Belgium and they take beer so seriously
there like every they you go into a bar
they would have like a hundred different
beers with a hundred different glasses
like each glass specifically designed to
bring
out the the the the optimum level of
flavor
of the like the way the beer is supposed
to taste it's just it's amazing it is
amazing all right Jesus Christ what do I
do next talk about
cigars um all right so I'm going to uh
yeah tomorrow technically I could smoke
a cigar I could have coffee but I don't
feel any desire to do it I'm definitely
not smoking
cigars I may have a coffee later on this
week but uh I don't feel any pressing
need to and you know what I do like is
back to taking naps in the
afternoon and uh that's good for the old
brain
there Jesus Bill what are you going to
talk about next your problems with your
feet I mean this is what the you know
I'm aging naturally people all right I'm
not taking oh oh oh oh [__] what is it
opri no is it
opri maybe it is that doesn't sound
right any well I'm not [__] looking
it up anyway that's a podcast everybody
go [__] yourselves and I will check in
on you on uh on
Thursday